you don't know who anyone is into to DET
test it and um I learned that c used to
tell me but I learned it uh he say you I
remember one time C I was a 17 18 year
old kid up there and you know thought I
was whatever I thought I was and he said
you got a lot of friends and um I said
yeah because you know I was on the
street hanging out with 100 kids at
night sometimes on the street corner so
I was like I didn't know too many people
that hung out with 100 Kids on the
street on a corner on a Friday Saturday
night and um I was like yeah I got a lot
of friends he goes
really yeah really he said
um how about if I told you you might not
have any most likely you don't have any
and he
goes and then he just started this thing
he said everyone's got to be tested
you me everyone because you don't know
about nobody to they tested he goes you
know nothing he goes you know nothing
until you know until something happens
to test if they were really a friend and
then he told me this story about a guy a
guy came to him and he was upset what
are you upset about he goes I'm upset
because I I I just uh I just lost a
friend uh you know after 20 years of
friendship we're not friends no more so
Co looks at him he
goes let me ask you a question what what
made you think you ever friends with him
now the guy gets insulted the guys did
you hear me he goes I I just told you 20
years I've been friends with this guy
why would you say that to me he said
well I say it again what makes you think
he was your friend he
goes what ever happened in the 20 years
other than chasing girls because CU
figured that one out fast chasing girls
and drinking together um and whatever
else you're doing out on the street
whatever gave you the
inclination that he was a friend yeah he
goes whatever when did he risk himself
to be a friend when was it dangerous to
be a friend when was the Friendship
tested when was it uncomfortable to be a
friend and you know what the guy said
you can figure it out you're a scientist
he
said
he said today
yeah